let's talk about the uh the Civil War
that's coming how about that guys we got
this one drink take a shot everybody
drink uh all right Arizona Sheriff steps
up security around ballot drop boxes
amid reports of intimidation I wanted I
wanted to ask you guys about this
because we have this story uh some guys
wearing bulletproof vests they had guns
they were in their uh Maricopa County
and they're uh sitting next to some
ballot drop boxes
apparently there's an organization
that's advocating for watching these
ballot boxes and I said this was going
to happen I said be you know after like
2 000 mules and after a lot of these
claims people are going to go to the
drop boxes and they are going to watch
then you're eventually going to see
antifa show up we've already had one
woman jump confront on the cops got
called
now the sheriff is sending I guess
Security Police to monitor these boxes
and uh I don't know does this escalate
the what the bulwark wrote and you know
we're all big fans of the bulwark
they're the conservative neocons who
hate Republicans it's weird they wrote
that their their their scenario that
they fear for escalation of civil war is
that at a polling location on the
midterms
someone is there observing someone on
the right they're armed they see someone
who they think is committing fraud or
something a fight breaks out a gunshot
rings out a poll workers on the ground
bleeding someone films it that was their
scenario my scenario is simpler
two guys show up they got bulletproof
vests and they got guns they're watching
the ballot Dropbox
a leftist walks up to him and starts
screaming saying get out of here you're
white supremacists a scuffle breaks out
nothing serious
the police are called and the police are
forced to start pushing people back
nobody can vote the polling location is
now closed and a dispute arises as to
whether or not the election can be
legitimate if polling locations are
being shut down
I don't know where we go from here
people don't have faith in these in
these drop boxes and just to take it
back a little bit I think it was Philly
where they had the new the Black Panther
Party that was intimidating voters back
maybe a decade ago or whatever nothing
happened so it goes back
you know we've had scuffles at polling
locations I think it was John Calhoun's
father who took guns to the legislature
to to get his own District or whatever
so fights occur in these places but
people do need to have faith we need
cameras we need enforcement mechanisms
um to make sure that there aren't you
know thousands of ballots being dropped
off it happened in Muskegon County in
Michigan I'm hearing stuff in Wisconsin
already you know it's happening right
now yeah I think it's happening I think
the question too is
which states allow ballot harvesting and
what you don't because some do well I
mean even in Wisconsin you know where I
served on Election Day and then helped
out with that investigation later
um you know there was a Supreme Court
decision there where they said you know
you can't ballot Harvest but I'm still
hearing that people come in with bags
you object and they don't listen to you
so it doesn't matter if the law in the
books is one thing if there's no way for
you to enforce it well I think I think
the issue right now depending on where
this goes is simple I think people
should be watching ballot boxes yeah I
think there should be cameras I think
there should be security uh hold on let
me slow down there shouldn't be ballot
drop boxes at all we should not have
election month we should have election
day it should be a Federal holiday
people should get time off to be able to
go and vote and then enjoy a nice beer
and pizza with their friends afterwards
or whatever but if we're gonna have any
kind of polling location then I think we
should have security cameras on
everything
that's it the crazy thing to me is how
is it vote the doj is getting involved
now calling it voter intimidation how is
it intimidating someone that you're
sitting there watching like you're
allowed to be in public you're allowed
to be armed you're allowed to wear armor
none of that is a crime if they start
screaming at people and chasing after
them and stuff yeah okay there you go
but they're claiming that someone came
up and then some people started taking
pictures of them and they're like that's
intimidation and it's like bro you're in
public it's the it's a different law but
it's the same story that we had with the
face act which is the freedom to access
Clinic entrances which they used against
abortion protesters that often would
just they're using right now right
they're using right now but but there
were some Supreme Court cases and you
can't be as aggressive but yeah they're
still using it here's another law where
they creatively apply it to people to to
get their preferred preferred ends so I
don't know what do you guys think is
going to happen
geez you want to go for it no you go
ahead oh man regarding these I kind of
agree I just think in general not even
just this I think where do we what
happens on the eighth unless you create
faith in the voting system as a whole I
think it's gonna slowly unravel and for
that it's like I don't like digitized
voting counting proprietary software
because I don't care if I'm mailing it
in handing it to a guy putting it in a
box and he's carrying it if it's being
tallied by a machine and the code's in
private I don't know if they're flipping
at 51.49 behind the scenes I've actually
seen testimony of like developer that
did that uh Clint Eugene Curtis Clint
Eugene Curtis I don't know if you ever
heard his story but what the he wrote
the software to flip the votes 5149 for
a politician so Democrats were were
making the same claims or Trump
supporters are making and you see the
Hillary Clinton thing already Hillary
Clinton came out and said the
Republicans are planning on stealing
2024. it's okay it's okay when she does
it it's it's you know I don't even I
don't even care at this point I'm just
like
the Democrat and Republican culture the
liberal and conservative culture is by
for it's it's two two distinct things
two completely different realities and
it's been that way for a long time and
now you've got both sides accusing each
other of cheating
I don't care who you think is right left
right up down whatever the fact is two
factions think both sides are stealing
the election both sides disagree with
each other's culture what how does that
resolve itself yeah is it is you know
just seriously to the people who think
it's silly when I say things like Civil
War do you think the end result is going
to be that like Hillary Clinton walks up
to Trump and says how could I stay mad
at you and then Trump's like come here
and they hug is it gonna be like the BLM
marcher with the black mascot and the
molotov see the Trump supporter with the
Maga flag and then he drops the mile top
and goes what have I become and the
Trump supporters come to your buddy and
they hug is there a Pepsi there and
Kylie Jenner that could work hey do they
think that Kylie Jenner is going to walk
up to a BLM and Trump supporter and hand
them both Pepsis then they're gonna both
look at each other and then hug
seriously though for what reason at any
point would any of this de-escalate I'm
looking for a legitimate
argument yeah I don't see it I don't see
any form of de-escalation I'm seeing a
lot of people adding fuel to the fire
I'm seeing this getting totally out of
hand this this building up of of calling
elections illegitimate has been
happening for many years now there the
groundwork has been set for this uh
specifically when we look at you know
the Trump election the the Russian
collusion and all the people coming
forward saying I don't trust this
election I don't trust this voting box I
don't trust this voting machine and I
think there are some you know legitimate
questions I think a lot of people are
also sensationalistic and hyperbolic in
a way that doesn't serve anyone's
interest but at the end of the day you
know that's a good question that you
asked here and that's something that
I've been thinking about for a very long
time and I see no off-road I see no way
of stopping this train coming ahead of a
major disaster inside of the United
States the only thing that I can see
that can fix this is if you do have one
party and I would say probably
Republican you know Landslide so that
their side can see faith in it and then
they win again and there's some kind of
strong agenda that they put in place
that can bring people to heels but if
the Republicans wins
down is about the only way that I can
see that this works excuse me wrong no
no uh I don't I don't agree
um I think that if we see an
overwhelming Republican Victory like
Luke was saying the Democrats will claim
the Republicans cheated the countries
become fascist and already there is this
viral tweet where someone said well
democracy is over what are you know what
are you going to do and someone
responded with I'm going to join the
resistance now look I'm not I'm not
confident the left has the ability to
form any meaningful resistance but
you need to you know uh I've been
harping on this because I've been
reading a lot more about the Civil War
The South was was a lot of States uh
relatively but not a lot of people it
was like two to one north to south they
were the minority a substantial minority
and then slave owners were an even
smaller minority
so
you know we may think like Democrats
might break Republican and independent
but looking at Hillary Clinton and her
cohorts and the cult members there's a
strong faction there and they're not
going to accept a trump Victory now now
here's a scenario to imagine
there's a Supreme Court ruling that's
coming soon that could set that may set
the precedent the state legislatures
decide who gets the electoral votes I
mean that's literally what the
Constitution says and for the longest
time the legislators have said oh we'll
do it we'll do an election
the people of our state vote
and then they vote for the electors to
go and do it we don't appoint them but
according to the Constitution the state
legislature legislature could appoint
the Electoral the electors however they
see fit it is to be determined by them
the way the country's supposed to work
we vote for our state reps Senators
Representatives they then represent us
to the federal government we've slowly
changed that with the popular vote for
the president and with the 17th
Amendment the popular vote for the
Senate that could change if this ruling
goes down imagine this scenario 2024
election
Donald Trump versus
Joe Biden whatever
the popular votes come in Biden gets it
the Statewide votes come in Electoral
College goes to Joe Biden but hold on
there a minute
lawsuits are immediately filed
questions are arise poll observers
Witnesses testimony comes out several
States say we cannot issue a
determination at this time this puts the
Electoral College up in the air two
things could happen
we could see the house do a simple vote
we saw this base off of house
delegations there was a concern that in
2020 because I think there were 26 house
delegations that were Republican or
something like that Donald Trump would
have won if it was pushed to a house
delegation vote
with this Supreme Court ruling something
else could happen
a state like Michigan simply says
evidence has been brought to our
attention which leads us to believe you
know the this amount of votes or that
amount of votes are not not uh correct
or are illegitimate therefore we as the
state legislature nullify them
the victory goes to Donald Trump
what would the left do in that position
they'll say Hillary Clinton predicted
this
the extremist Maga Republicans are
stealing the country and then what do
you think they just say but I guess I'll
go hang out at home this has happened
before I mean there have been there have
been cases where states have flipped and
I don't I don't see anything wrong with
that process per se I mean you know the
whole thing about
you know you can you can get into
Republican form of government problems
if the state legislature's not even
holding an election or something like
that but at the end of the day there
have to be processes in place to to
count the votes to make sure that
there's a state actor who's certifying
things and sending them to the archivist
and and whatnot so I I don't see a
problem it's happened before I guess the
main thing I'll say is I don't really
see that as happening because
you know look at what happened in 2020
Mike Pence you know wouldn't look under
the hood nobody looked under the hood
you know you go state after State people
don't check under the hood because
they've got people beating down their
door so I don't see that happening you
gave Michigan as an example I don't see
you know Sharky or whatever his name is
the the lead at the legislature there uh
entertaining that sort of a thing
um you know time and time again Arizona
Michigan Wisconsin
um you see week Republican leadership
that doesn't do that so I don't I don't
really see that as as a as so much of a
possibility I see the more thing I see
is is States battening down the hatches
in these purple areas on behalf of blue
candidates it's all very dubious and no
one ever has their their views aired out
nobody ever checked under the hood so
the clips are coming yeah right already
I got one from regular rice anything we
can play the beginning we actually
missed the beginning when fetterman said
hi good night really yeah I I reposted
that one yeah so fetterman is asked to
clarify whether he supports fracking
quote I support fracking and I don't I
support fracking and I stand and I do
support fracking
great
I love how they brought out the
information and he immediately says I
never supported fracking it's like we
literally just read on the screen that
said You supported fracking in 2018 I
don't know how you're gonna how you're
gonna debate that or like the other way
around that he didn't support fracking
in 20 no I don't know he didn't I think
he said he did the thing about fracking
and nobody really brought it up is when
they first were doing it it was really
uh dirty and they've Advanced the
chemicals that they inject in
underground so it's a lot cleaner right
from what I've heard there's an EPA
thing it wasn't like the workers it was
like the the runoff and stuff like that
I just want to see someone splice his
answer about I get knocked down and I
get up again
yeah yeah
to the victim mindset like if you're a
victim then I'm your guy yeah victims
versus surgeon I'm a surgeon yeah versus
a guy who saves people's lives did you
know I was a surgeon
surgery by bringing people together
David harassany says if Dasha Burns was
guilty of anything it was downplaying
the extent of fetterman's problems and I
recall all the feigned outrage Giselle
fetterman demanding consequences Dasha
Burns interviewed fetterman he had to
use a special device and she said
that during the small talk it wasn't
clear he understood what what she was
saying and a bunch of people on the left
said that it's ableist that someone with
mental disabilities and brain damage
should be allowed to hold office and you
know they were outraged and uh they said
that she was
wrong and it was offensive and that
criticizing fetterman was akin to
criticizing someone who needed reading
glasses
wow Governor Abbott a cursory viewing of
the debate determined that was a lie
Dasha Burns probably could have been a
bit harsher on fetterman
that was CR I can't believe he agreed to
do it I mean Katie Hobbs won't debate
Carrie Lake
fetterman could have just been like nah
he's up two points what is he got to
lose well I think they know the buys and
the polls favors Oz and so he had no
choice
that was bad I mean are they trying to
lose
that crossed my mind but it was kind of
a joke like is is fetterman a plant
trying to get Oz elected like does he
work for Dr Oz are we going to find out
yours maybe like they were always
friends no he's just a guy that broke
and now but he doesn't want to let go of
what he used to have maybe the reason he
said uh
you know I support fracking and I don't
is so that the Democrats are able to
make a video of him answering however
they want him to answer do you support
for asking I don't fracking I don't I'm
sorry I pulled the Thunderman do you
support fracking I don't I stand and
then they're going to be like oh then
they're one commercial saying it
I think I think obviously they've just
been like the floor is yours John speak
just go for it yeah
I do think Oz needed the chance to
explain his positions though
yeah it was enlightening to listen to
yeah we didn't get into anything else
though we had you know Kanye stuff
what's the Kanye
yeah Kanye's net worth went from what
two billion to one to six hundred
million ish he's lost about three
fourths as well because it's Adidas
steel was canceled Adidas canceled
they're uh I don't even know what the
deal was but apparently he's made him
worth 1.5 billion Doug Yeezys go for
hundreds of dollars easy shoes they're
called I I you know I just like I've
never never wore I've seen I've seen him
before and then I was just like I
ordered I wrote a couple pairs when they
said they were canceling them or
whatever I'm like all right you know
whatever not that I don't think I'm not
going to sell them or anything I'm gonna
put on my shelf and just be like you
know hey these were a thing once it
could have been his uh the Kanye West
Lex Friedman interview was eye-open I
think everybody saw at least a clip from
it
yeah yeah it was kind of worth it it was
more of an I think it was an attempt by
Lex to emotionally connect with Kanye
and they were both trying to be like hey
we don't know each other we both are
Engineers of A Sort let's be friends was
the kind of of the I what they went into
it and it was contentious and kind of a
mess because I didn't watch it I I read
it and it just read to me as smarmy like
he was talking down to Kanye and trying
to play the what's the problem man I
agree yeah I was I was like There's an
opportunity to have a conversation with
Kanye that's that's that's real and asks
him to you know explain himself better
but I didn't I didn't get that interview
it felt like it was very much like
here's what the media said so I'm gonna
I'm gonna argue with you about it and
Kanye was getting frustrated he was like
dude
and then Lex gave him the do you trust
me and Kanye was like no thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there